just a short time ago the White House
announced the president tested negative
for kovat 19 after coming in contact
with a Brazilian official who was
infected
let's bring in former White House
physician and a congressional candidate
dr. Ronnie Jackson also a retired Navy
Rear Admiral
dr. Jackson thanks very much for being
with us given what happened with given
with the what happened with the
Brazilian delegation and with the press
secretary from Brazil's presidential
office testing positive for coronavirus
was it appropriate for president Trump
to take that test
well John I'll tell you you know I think
the president's trying to you know abide
by the same rules that we're going to
apply to everybody else in this country
with regards to testing and be honest
with you I don't think there was a
clinical indication for to get a test I
think that it was much like the
situation that I was in if you remember
back when I did his his physical exam
his first physical exam and I did the
cognitive testing there was no
indication for the cognitive testing
either but there comes a point where the
narrative is all about just that and you
have to do something just to move on to
whatever's next and actually put it to
bed and I think that's pretty much what
happened here I don't think there was a
clinical indication to do the test I
think that they looked at the weather
where the president failed with regards
to risk based on these exposures and I
think that what they ultimately decided
and I think the president had a big role
in this just like he did when I did the
cognitive testing he just said hey let's
just do the test let's get this over
with let's put it to bed and let's move
on I mean he's working hard to try to
take care of our country here and keep
us all safe and I think you know the the
press some of the liberal press and
those on the Left are really spun this
up and we have other things we need to
move on and focus on so I'm glad that he
got the test done I'm glad that it's
negative and I hope that we can move on
down and it's not trying to make
political hay just carry on we just put
up some of the bullet points of the
contents contents of this family's first
coronavirus respond response act and
there they are again
is there anything else that that you
think should be in the legislation well
I can't see I can't see what you have on
the screen there but I mean I think that
the legislation is good based on what I
know about it what I've read I think
that there's probably stuff in there you
know
it was forced to now think you know
that's kind of what upsets me as just an
American here is that sometimes they're
there folks that are using the crisis
like this for political advantage and to
get things into legislation that maybe
shouldn't be in there that don't
necessarily address the problem so I'd
have to look at everything but I think
from what I've heard with the testing
and the access and things of that nature
I think it's probably appropriate I'm
sure the president wouldn't have you
know signed off on it it had not been
something that's that's appropriate for
facing the president also has declared a
national emergency I want to play for
you now some of the reasons that he said
he decided to do that listen yesterday I
declared a national emergency which was
a very big deal because it opened up
avenues that we would never be able to
open up without it it'll make more than
50 billion dollars available to us
immediately in disaster relief funds I'm
still struck by how much life is
changing in this country as a result of
this virus that although it has killed
some people it's a relatively small
number and primarily elderly people and
people who were you know had underlying
medical conditions in a couple of weeks
in a month are we gonna look back on
this and say you know we went overboard
on this do you think dr. Jackson or are
these steps simply prudent well you know
these steps are proven because we just
don't know but I hope you're right and I
think you are right I think we will look
back on this and instead we overreacted
a little bit I guess it's better to be
safe than sorry you know in some regards
but you know I think that this thing's
been spun for political reasons and I
think that a lot of people have really
gone overboard with it just you know and
it created a lot of fear that doesn't
need to be there I mean I'm telling you
I'm talking to here from Amarillo Texas
and I just went to a Saint Patrick's Day
parade and shamrock Texas this morning
and folks here not getting too spun up
about it you know they're out there and
you know there weren't a lot of elderly
people out there so people are
protecting their grandparents and their
elderly parents making sure they stay
home and they bring groceries to them
and do things like that but the rest of
us that are young and otherwise healthy
we're getting out or not letting this
really just destroy our lives and it's
having a big impact on the economy and
we need to be able to get out and be
together to some extent we're taking
Prakash
we're washing our hands there's a lot of
sanity hand sanitizer out there things
of that nature but I think that we will
look back on this John and we will see
that this was a little bit overblown or
quite a bit overblown hopefully and
we'll be able to move on and do better
next time yeah when you look at the
store shelves that have been cleaned out
you look at the the athletic seasons
competitions that have been cancelled
universities that are canceling classes
to me it's it's unbelievable what is
happening as a result John's buyers
quickly yes I would say if you look at
this potentially going on for weeks and
weeks we can't sustain something like
that so we need to figure out how to how
to take a reasonable approach to this
and I think we we've gone a little bit
too far too fast with the cancellations
and the things that that nature the
president is working really hard with a
really great team to protect us and we
need to trust him to do that
unfortunately in this litigious society
people don't want to be held responsible
for you know getting this thing to turn
around dr. Ronnie Jackson it's good to
have you on thank you